هل تعرف سابقه في تاريخ الحروب
الاسرائيليه الكثيره ان دب الشقاق بين
القيادتين العسكريه
و السياسيه بهذه
الطريقه ليس بهذه الصوره وليس اثناء الحرب
واثناء المعارك الجاريه وهذا الشقاق انا
برايي الذي اصبح واضحا وغير مسبوق هو
نتيجه واضح نتيجه لامر واضح وجلي وهو
الفشل الاسرائيلي نحن نتحدث هنا عن فشلين
الفشل الاول الكبير في 7 اكتوبر
استراتيجيا وعسكريا
واستخباراتياً الولايات المتحده الهجمه
الاسرائيليه تفشل في تحقيق اهدافها لا
حرروا اسرى ولا استطاعوا ان يقتلع
المقاومه ولا استطاعوا ان يفرضوا سيطره
دباباتهم على اي منطقه دخلوها ولا
استطاعوا ان ينفذوا الهدف المركزي للعمليه
العسكريه وهو التطهير العرقي لسكان قطاع
غزه بفضل بطوله وبساله اهل غزه كما يقال
النصر له اباء عديدين والفشل والهزيمه
يتيمه لذلك مع راه اليوم هو تمهيد لرفع
السكاكين ضد بعضهم البعض ولطعم بعضهم
البعض في من يتحمل المسؤوليه عن الفشل
الاول والفشل الثاني العسكريون يريدون ان
يحملوا المسؤوليه على على على كاهل
السياسيين والسياسيون يريدوا ان يبحثوا عن
كبش فداء بين العسكريين وهذه هي طبيعه
الصراع الجاري ولذلك تم تشكيل هذه اللجنه
ه اللجنه التي شكلها قائد الجيش لانه يريد
ان يمنع تحميل ل العسكريين المسؤوليه عن
الفشل الكبيرين الذين الذان تعيشه ما
اسرائيل الان ا